it was clear in july that our relations
were uh very far from where they had
been
and they took another terrible dive
after this after the second lockdown in
october because the prime minister knew
that i blamed him
for the whole situation and i did
and you know by the 31st of october our
relations were essentially already
finished the fact that his girlfriend
also wanted rid of me was you know
relevant but not the heart of the heart
of the problem
the other problem was uh fundamentally i
regarded him as unfit for the job
and i was trying to create a structure
around him to try and
stop what i thought were extremely bad
decisions and push other things through
against his wishes
and he had the view that he was prime
minister and i should just be doing as
he wanted me to and that's obviously not
sustainable very long
and i only stayed because i was
desperate to try and push through
action as just to stop as many
people dying as i could do once the
second lockdown happened it was
on the 31st then it was obvious that i
was going to be gone within days
and remember i'd already said that i was
going to go by the friday the 18th of
december
in july so it was not really anything
the thing that i got wrong and the thing
that i terribly regret
now is
on the tuesday the 22nd after we've done
that theoretical meeting
set in the future five six weeks which
i'd organized
and he saw all the data and he said that
at that point i was already going in
kind of 12 weeks anyway
what i ought to have done is said to him
then uh
i'm resigning in 48 hours we can do this
one way i can do this the other way
if you announce that you're going to
have a lockdown and take serious action
now i will leave go quietly with all
friends
if you don't i'll call the press
conferences say the prime minister's
making a terrible decision that's going
to kill thousands of people
and i should have gambled on holding a
gun to his head essentially
and who knows if that would have worked
or not but fundamentally
it was kind of all upside given that my
role there was basically done at that
point